We love to end every podcast with are the,
are the worst game and the best game.
So just to you,
what is the game ?
Could be Lion King could be something else
in a personal fashion that you
are just, your worst game.
(sighs)
The worst game.
That's a big sigh!
That's a long one.
It's a lot of them running
for first place right now.
(laughing)
The worst game.
Uhm.
Oo,
Pac-Man
Oh!
Yeah, not a, not a popular opinion.
Personal vendetta against Pac-Man
Absolutely. No question. Absolutely.
Oh, no!
Absolutely. Oh no, just,
I'm just not good at it.
(everyone laughing)
Is there something in your past?
There's a, I mean, Pac-Man.
Yeah.
(everyone laughing)
That's in the past. Yeah.
That's it, that's the thing.
That's the whole thing.
I just, it was, it was
innovative in its time,
but I was born after that.
So, you know,
Yeah.
When was Pac-Man, Pac-Man was 81?
I was born in 84. We had advanced by then.
Fuck that guy.
(laughing)
No time for Pac-Man.
No time for that! Ridiculous.
(laughing)
It was just re, it was
still very much hyped up
when I started playing
games and it was, you know,
it was everywhere.
Every, any teen place I went to,
it was always a Pac-Man arcade there.
And people started making
the tabletop Pac-Man
and I was just never good at it.
And it was just so hyped up.
And I was like, why,
why is everybody playing this game?
I was so toxic about that game.
You know, people would
get mad at Overwatch.
And then when they see
you playing it like,
it's a dead game, that's a dead game.
I don't know why you're
still playing that game.
(laughing)
That was me with Pac-Man.
That was it.
(everyone laughing)
Yeah, yeah.
Like I'm no good, it's a dead game.
It's a dead game.
Yeah. I was just salty.
Nobody plays that game anymore.
I'm the only one not playing it and shit.
Yeah, nobody plays that.
I was just salty. I was salty as hell.
Still am. As you can.
Still? Oh my God. Clear.
I can feel it.
Rocks of salt, huge salt licks.
I can feel it a little.
Pac-Man it's a power palace, just.
That very impressionable
first five years of your life where
everybody's talking about Pac-Man
and then you try to play it and
just like, Nope!
Yeah.
It's stuck.
I don't, I don't understand.
I don't have hand eye
coordination right now.
Cause I'm a child.